you
yeah it's Monday [ __ ] Yong chol Joey
here in full [ __ ] effect you
have to be on a [ __ ] Monday you
understand me
August 29th the day the devil was buried
at sea [ __ ] in the ass and dragged by
a [ __ ] car by his horse you are fired
did you want fire
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive get your [ __ ] together you
understand me [ __ ] the hollered their
buddies walking alone it's Labor Day
what kind of macaroni salad should I
make who gives a [ __ ] it's Monday [ __ ]
worried about Labor Day Mex [ __ ] at
Monday today you gotta worry about
what's [ __ ] in front like
tonight I'm at the goddamn calmly jet
with my man Josh Adam is at 8 o'clock
how'd you get a [ __ ] meeting stag
that's a day from hell you know what
they say do you want to walk around in
heaven you never spend a few [ __ ]
days and they'll be Joey what you to
chitter chatter what do you got in the
cabin today oh [ __ ]
I got some [ __ ] presidential
push but my brother's up there black
leaves they showed up at the county
store last night with some cookies some
[ __ ] muffins holidays on the [ __ ]
cookie it was a sleeping pill I loved it
it only was 150 milligrams I hate when I
slept like a [ __ ] baby
I got up in the middle of my pissed like
this smell the [ __ ] THC and the [ __ ]
Organic [ __ ] THC and the reef or the
whole thing but listen who gives a [ __ ]
Joey I don't really give a [ __ ] into one
if you're gonna spark spark if not I got
[ __ ] to do listen son why
there was a little beautiful [ __ ] mud
right here to get your day started but I
made a kale shake if did ten sit-ups
right here's what you need to get your
[ __ ] they started focused right in
all the knobs you right even like
[ __ ] get the TV and it's [ __ ] up
the radio you have to play with the
mound that rifo gets you right on your
[ __ ] line you can swing that make a
professional the rest of the day
understand I'm telling you I guarantee
all these people taking medications is
[ __ ] this is the [ __ ] medication of
life friendly to take two [ __ ] three
bits of this [ __ ] and your days come
sequence ah you're not confused you know
[ __ ] up being an anxious
the smoke from the retha wakes the
spirits up around you like what the
[ __ ] he smoking we gotta get to work
[ __ ] so don't look at me with three
[ __ ] eyes I'm telling you right now
this wakes you up in the morning puts
you in a good mood
focus is use make sure zero in on the
[ __ ] kill okay if you don't believe
me I don't give a [ __ ]
I've been using it for years and every
day I get tuned up in the morning and I
miss my damage when I finish it with you
are going there make 19 [ __ ] phone
calls and 32 emails and tell us what
people suck my dick on 20 minutes
understand me that's what tarifa destiny
or you declare lunatic ain't about my
Pinoy your soy le or some DC metallic
gold I'm me seeking bathroom color
Karina sorry
so put your [ __ ] batteries in today
because so they were going deep the
podcast is up with Bert Kreischer we
talk about a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
it's just a Monday conversation don't
expect much just a Monday morning
conversation
but the Icehouse friends they make the
small rule no expectations' next ders
they have a 'slap-ass I'm working Island
especially people and never worked this
hard in my life as I never gave a [ __ ]
about anything in my life
but you guys have lifted the bar in my
life so now I gotta come with two
[ __ ] guns and a backpack with a
[ __ ] explosive in the understand
there's you know I'm coming from I can't
show up with some knock-knock jokes you
guys that give me all the love and
support anybody can give a [ __ ] at
felony understand me son I show up and
make you [ __ ] proud
you do know that speed with Los Angeles
has the stars and they'll deliver right
to your [ __ ] house in the middle all
night you do know that that Gino don't
[ __ ] around if it's [ __ ] tremendous
Gino's that man Gino's not stupid he's
got the stars at that so if you're in LA
right now you feel hunky-dory a little
bored Cosby weed and let them deliver
some [ __ ] stars at that the house
right there you don't have to move you
don't forget off the couch who's better
than you
we got a nice doctor police is breathing
inside the THC you hold your breath a
little bit come on guys for fun but will
you get this information from them
Anthony [ __ ]
you know why Illinois you think I don't
know what I'm [ __ ] talking about it
the deeper you get the deeper it goes
this is good as it gets this is
simplicity and his best every try to
make a big deal about everything matters
what is this a little ball two three
hits nobody gets their feelings hurt
we have been assaulted no Barney we
[ __ ] just sang what maybe we'll take
this [ __ ] to the top
doesn't get no better than this
I'm gonna go through some kettlebells
around get myself hyperventilated to get
the fat burning and go to jiu-jitsu and
get choked out of town sometimes that's
the only reason why go to jiu-jitsu then
I'm gonna do my [ __ ] mobility class
I'm gonna wash my [ __ ] come home have a
piece of fish and shoot right back to
meet some [ __ ] do it about a dog on
the other side of [ __ ] town and then
never ends I got to pick up my daughter
like ever come home me you shoot down a
[ __ ] the Roxie baby to do a little
Rage Against the Machine and that's it
that's my [ __ ] day okay I'll be
around if you need me hit me up on
Twitter you know we get together
whatever the [ __ ] you wanna do remember
you show up it'll show up a roll of
papers show up with the [ __ ] that save
[ __ ] punches part
very nice see the smoke goes into the
[ __ ] phone it's open anywhere I love
you [ __ ] get your head together
write your polls do your flop in 22
push-ups and get out there cuz nobody's
gonna do it for you once you figure out
that nobody's gonna do Dixie [ __ ]
connections by nothing yet but you gotta
do it yourself do the [ __ ] steps grab
your balls [ __ ] all that nonsense once
you figure out at all and your shoulders
it makes your world a lot [ __ ] easier
I got a hookup at the hotel here you
gotta hook them how many pics you got a
[ __ ] smoke them up and get that job
take care yourself [ __ ] watch
your own back be a good friend to
yourself [ __ ] these little idiots I have
to go to his birthday party get the [ __ ]
outta here
anyway I love you [ __ ] with all
my heart
have a great day tell them I wanna suck
your dick and if you're confused you're
feeling down smoke bomb what the [ __ ] Oh
take the edge off go out there the
world's a better place alright I love
you [ __ ] don't forget the podcast
is ready for you a perforation beside
that stay black